MALE SPEAKER 1: Shanghai GDG
is a very interesting
developer community.
FEMALE SPEAKER 1: I'm
glad somebody
has asked this question.
MALE SPEAKER 2: This is where
the magic happens.
FEMALE SPEAKER 2: This is
primarily a question and
answer show, so if any
of you out there
would like to ask questions.
COLT MCANLIS: Hello.
Hello.
I'm live?
Fantastic, awesome.
They're telling me I'm live,
so hello everyone.
Welcome.
Thank you so much for coming
to our GDL session, talking
about webify your game.
I am your host for the day.
My name is Colt McAnlis, and I'm
a developer advocate here
working at Google, focusing
on web gaming.
What I want to talk to you guys
about today, I want to
take about 30 minutes of your
time, 30 to 45 minutes, and
talk about how you can make
more successful games, and
what you need to be doing in
this ecosystem that we have in
order to prosper.
I think to understand that, we
need to take a step back.
We need to go all the way back
to 2009 and take a look at the
gaming ecosystem at that time.
In 2009, two major
things happened.
Number one was the rise
of web social gaming.
We saw a lot of social
distributed gaming coming
through the cloud, coming
through these viral networks,
being able to tap a new
generation, a new bucket of
customers that typically weren't
considered gamers.
These weren't people that big
gaming companies were
advertising to, or even thought
that there was a
market there.
Number two that happened in 2009
was that we finally saw
the boom of the mobile gaming.
Now the mobile ecosystem had
been there for a number of
years, but really didn't
come into its
stride until about 2009.
Now, the rise of these two
things brought something to
game development the no one
had really seen before.
And that was that any game
developer could go out and
make a very small budget game
and get it in front of
millions of people.
When you have this vacuum that
was created for demand, of
individuals wanting content both
in the social game space
as well as the mobile space, it
gave rise to something that
none of us really expected
at the time.
But it really generated the
indie game developer.
And this is a situation where
you have sort of the casual
development space of just
making websites, or easy
scripting, or people who come
to the table wanting small
content, coupled with sort of
the high-precision, high
frequency game development
processes that we'd seen in
AAA development, as well as
skill sets that had come to
the world for mobile handheld
development that we've seen
from other large publishers.
And this really gave rise to
this developer who basically
became our fan icon for the
games industry overnight.
It seemed like we were flooded
with tons and tons of stories
about how individuals would
spend the weekend in the
garage making a game, and
putting it up on the web or
mobile, and then turning around
and making $100,000 on
it in the next week.
And this type of information,
when received by the general
populace of game developers,
created what I like to call
the modern gaming gold rush.
We had tons and tons and tons
of developers leaving their
established companies with
401(k)s and stock options,
branching out into the
world of unknown self
entrepreneurship, looking to
make the next big game.
And a lot of them actually had
a very, very good success.
Now over time, though, we have
to come to the conclusion that
it's no longer 2009.
In fact, it's 2012 now, and
a lot of the things that
happened back then are
no longer the case.
First off, a lot of these social
games in the social
networks have kind
of taken a fall.
What we've seen is that the
social networks themselves
have reduced a lot of the
sharing and viral features
that originally made those first
generation of games so
successful and so popular.
It was very easy for them to
basically flood your stream of
information with, buy my pink
cow, buy my pink cow.
In addition to that, because of
the early success, we saw a
huge influence and a huge pool
of money come in from venture
capitalists and other small
game development studios,
which effectively just
flooded the space.
There's tons of clones, tons of
one-offs, everyone trying
to do the same thing with a
different skin to kind of keep
your eyeballs and get
your attention
through their clicks.
On the other side of the
dime is mobile gaming.
Now what mobile gaming
has done now--
don't get me wrong,
mobile gaming is
doing amazingly well.
In fact, I think the latest
statistics still show like
some 27 billion million umpteen
zillion devices that
are released and activated
every day.
But what we're seeing there
is that the market and the
ecosystem has been driven more
by indie game developers than
any other ecosystem.
And the result there has been
just a flood of content, just
an overwhelming number of
applications that have ended
up in that ecosystem.
And the result has kind of been
difficult, because large
game developers, publishers who
traditionally weren't in
the space before, have now
entered into the space, and
are competing against these
indies for the same little 128
pixels by 96 pixel screen real
estate in the promotional
systems that are there.
So the indies are coming to the
table with lots of great
ideas and having to fight
against people with lots of
marketing dollars.
Which means something very
interesting, is that with the
birth of everything that
happened in 2009, it's never
been easier or more
cost-effective to make a game
and get it in front of
millions of people.
The problem though, is it's
still just as hard to market
that game and actually convince
all the people in the
crowd that your content
is worth looking at.
So what we end up with, is you
have a whole fleet of indie
developers all making content,
expecting the environment to
still resemble what it looked
like in 2009, when
that's not the case.
So what should you be doing?
If you're a game developer
today, how do you get your
message out?
How you embrace users?
How do you market your product
properly when this may not be
necessarily be your
wheelhouse?
The good news is that there's
a very established ecosystem
that's well-versed in
understanding how to get your
signal out there with lots of
noise in the ecosystem.
And that multiverse is
called the internet.
So the question really for this
talk, and what I really
want to address to everyone here
today is what can the web
to teach us about making
more successful games?
And I'm not saying put all
your games on the web.
I'm talking about learning and
adapting and bringing the
principles and traits of the web
into your game development
process, and your game, to
make it more successful.
Or better yet, what makes
clicking a link and seeing a
cat such a compelling vehicle
for content that people
continuously do it?
That cat right there alone has
some ungodly number of
hundreds of thousands
of views.
That's an amazing vehicle
and an amazing process.
So what we're going to talk
about today is three ways that
you're going to be able to
webify your game, and
hopefully, or more specifically,
have success in
making better games.
The first part is going to be to
ship all of your platforms.
Now there's a great story that
I'm going to tell, and if this
story's about you,
I apologize.
I was actually at a game
developer conference a few
weeks ago, and talked to a lot
of people on the floor, and
was just getting a pulse on
what game developers were
going through.
And I was talking to this
developer who was lamenting
over the state of the mobile
ecosystem, and how he wasn't
making millions and millions
of dollars like he was
expecting to.
And so I said to him, hey that's
cool, how are you doing
in the other ecosystems?
How are you doing not on mobile,
or in the competing
mobile ecosystem?
And his response was, I'm
not in those ecosystems.
I'm only in this one place.
You can only find
my program here.
And I kind of stopped and looked
at him, like wait,
you're not anywhere else?
Why are you not embracing
these other ecosystems?
He says, well, I don't think
it's worth my time, and/or I
don't have money to do it.
This was not news to me.
But I definitely think it was
one of those spots where I can
honestly say, I believe
that game developers
are doing it wrong.
If you're a game developer and
you're making a piece of
content, you should be
understanding that the success
of your studio and the success
of your content is directly
related to how many people can
access it and purchase it.
In marketing or in sales,
you call this
the top of the funnel.
If you only have two million
potential customers, and you
hope to get 10% out of it, is
that going to keep your studio
afloat over time?
This is the critical question.
Should you be locking your
content only to one platform?
There's a great quote by
a guy named Mark Cuban.
Hopefully you know who he is.
His comment is, make your
product easier to buy than
your competition or you're going
to find them buying your
competitor product
instead of yours.
Now this is very important.
So let's take a real world
application for example.
Let's say you've
got a headache.
I've got a really bad headache,
and I'm sitting at
home, and I'm out of any
headache medicine.
I get my car.
I'm going to drive to the
closest, most convenient place
to get headache medicine.
I'm going to walk in the store,
and I'm going to pick
from the things that are
available on that shelf for me
to purchase.
Now if your product isn't being
served or delivered
there, then there's no
opportunity for me to purchase
your product.
Even though I may like
I may know your product.
I may have purchased it two
miles down the road in a
different store.
The fact is that right now,
I'm going to choose the
easiest option to purchase
the product as possible.
So what happens is, let's say
you have your content.
Your content's out in the wild,
and you put it on a
specific platform.
Well that's fine for the users
that have already breached the
barrier of entry to get
to your content.
This is pretty easy for them.
You just have to find a way to
connect from your platform to
the people.
But there's a whole group of
people over here who maybe
entirely willing to
pay you oodles of
money for your content.
You may find your true fans
here, or your connoisseurs, or
your collectors, who have no
ability to actually access
your content because they may
not already be on the
platform, or are unwilling to
adopt that platform due to
various reasons.
Maybe they don't sign up for an
email, or they don't want
to buy $700 worth of hardware
in order to then pay extra
money for your content.
And really what you should be
doing, is because of the fact
that games are digitally
distributable--
we have the ability to just go
and download the content--
you should really be embracing
the ability to allow the user
to get the content directly
from you as the developer.
Four or five years ago, this
kind of was unheard of because
of the avenues online.
It was really hard for a
standard developer to actually
put the product online and sell
it to people directly.
There was lots of DRM
issues out there.
Console was kind of
the big thing.
A lot of people didn't
put focus in this.
But today, in 2012,
is very different.
I want to talk to specifically
about a great success story.
There's a game out there
called Gratuitous Space
Battles, by Positech Games.
And it's a fantastic game.
It's beautifully done.
It's all in 2D.
And it was done by basically a
little indie developer that
shipped it in 2009.
Now the developer of this, Cliff
Harris, actually came
out at a great talk called World
of Love a long time ago.
And the whole point of his talk
was, hey, I'm an indie.
I need money.
Here's how I'm going outside of
these channels to market my
game and get money from
other avenues.
And one of the big things he
came to with this was that he
believed dominantly that you
should be allowing users to
buy from your website.
And in fact, if you actually
visit the Gratuitous Battles
website, you can actually
see tons of icons there.
You can buy with Amazon, with
PayPal, with Google Checkout.
There is a plethora of ways
for you to give him your
money, if you already are
signed in, or have an
established rapport, or an
account on file, and whatnot.
This is really cool, because it
allows him to effectively
connect with his customers
outside of the ebb and flow of
digital distribution
platforms.
He can actually connect at
a much deeper level.
And his website goes on
further to say this.
If you actually got us website,
he's got a great quote.
He says, you should buy from
us because of the fact that
when you buy from us, I
get 91% of the money.
Only 9% actually goes to the
credit card payment people.
And this is really cool, because
this allows him to
actually connect with
his users, say
hey, I'm a real person.
I have a real job.
Please buy the content
directly from me.
It's fantastic.
He goes on further to say if
you do buy from me, I will
send you pictures of cats.
Now where else on the internet
are you going to be able to
find the ability to connect with
users like this at that
deep of a level?
You can't actually connect
like this in digital
distribution platforms.
Specifically, when a user wants
your product, they have
to go to some site that explains
your product, and
accept permissions and
get it from there.
No, these guys over here that
make Gratuitous Space Battles
are telling you, please, buy my
product and I will give you
pictures of cats.
Only on the internet can you
have that sort of relationship
with the user.
And best off, look at that.
He's saying that if you give me
your email and don't even
buy the product, I'll just
send you cat pictures.
This is great.
He has the ability to create an
entire marketing chain and
email list, a group of people
who are interested in his
product, and are willing to
receive pictures of cats, that
he can then market
to over time.
He has the ability to have a
connection with his user
because they're going direct
to his website that other
developers can't get because
they're relying entirely on a
silo distribution.
And with this, you have to
understand that you also get
other benefits.
And the second thing is, from
our three set, is that with
the ability to connect with
your user, you have the
ability to actually talk
with them earlier.
You have the ability to
get their feedback.
You have the ability to make
changes and make a product
that they actually care about.
So anyone know this guy?
This is Michelangelo.
He's very famous for carving
this statue,
the statue of David.
Now when Michelangelo was later
in his life, he actually
give a great quote to someone
that says, "Along with the
milk of my nurse, I received the
knack of handling a chisel
and hammer, with which
I make my figures."
Now for those of you don't know
the life of Michelangelo,
his family actually fell on some
hard times, and he, as a
young child, actually had to
go live with his wet nurse.
The wet nurse and her
family actually
lived in a marble quarry.
The father of the family
actually mined marble, which
meant that Michelangelo, as a
young child living in this
environment, had marble just
laying around his house for
him to play with.
During this entire time, he was
able to go outside, chisel
marble, play with marble,
manipulate marble.
He had a feedback loop of how
to play with marble that his
competitors had never gotten.
He had spend more time failing
and playing with marble by the
time he was 12 than any other
sculptors had done their
entire lifetime, because
how expensive
marble was at that time.
The point of this was that
Michelangelo had found that
iteration in a medium resulted
in better results.
And the fact that he could
iterate better than his
competitors resulted
in his success.
And the statue David is a
perfect example of that.
AAA game development does
not necessarily follow
this path very well.
Now what you see with a big
budget title typically in a
console development cycle right
now, is that you end up
with an early prototype phase.
And then you'll probably go
through about two or three
years worth of development
cycle.
And only then, after the
internal development cycle for
three years, will you actually
go into public beta.
Now take a look at this.
The only time that the public,
the consumers, the people that
are actually going to be buying
the product, have
actually seen the product and
played with the product, is
during this beta phase.
This means that all of the
feedback that they've gotten
on their content has
been internal only.
With that in mind, it kind of
makes a lot of sense that most
console games always ship
their slip date.
Once you go into beta, you get
all this feedback from people
saying these icons are wrong, or
I don't like this, or this
thing is overpowered, or they
stress the system in new ways,
and then the shipping gets
slipped again and again, or as
long as they financially
can hand out.
And then finally the product
hits the shelves.
Now what this means is, if you
look at this development
cycle, you end up with a four
year development span costing
$40 million, where the user
is only brought in the
conversation the last
25% or 30%.
Those are the people actually
buying your product.
And yet you don't actually have
a conversation with them
about the product until much
later in the cycle.
What you actually see is that
they're going through this.
Internally, they say, is this
product awesome yet?
If not, let's change
a bunch of stuff
and see if it's again.
And then oops, we ran out
of time, let's ship it.
The problem here again is that
there should be a bubble in
there where it says, is this
awesome yet, consumer?
And the consumer says, yes or
no, here's my feedback.
Minecraft is a perfect example
of where this went right.
For those of you guys who don't
know the story of how
Minecraft got off the ground,
in 2009, Minecraft actually
went public with an alpha.
And with that, you could
actually buy the alpha and get
the full version later.
Effectively, what the developers
were doing is, they
still had day jobs.
They shipped Minecraft
on the side.
And they said, hey, if you're
willing to pay me now, $20,
$25, something like that, then
when the full version comes
out later, you'll get the full
version plus all the upgrades
and all the other cool stuff.
What this allowed them to do
was actually find a pool of
true fans, people actually cared
about the product, early
this development cycle, that are
willing to pay for it and
then receive feedback
from it over time.
The result of this was
actually amazing.
In 2010, they actually
shipped their beta.
And, funny story, the actual
company was founded in 2010,
when Paypal actually suspended
their account from the alpha
purchases, when it ended up with
like $700,000 in there.
PayPal actually thought it was
a hack, some piracy was going
on, something bad
was happening.
And they had to found their
company in order to properly
receive these funds
and tunnel them
into development properly.
The cool thing about this is
that users were paying the
company to provide feedback
about their product.
In any other medium that you
want external feedback, you
usually have to go
pay someone else.
If you want a consultant to come
in and tell you how your
blinds should be shaped, or you
want external writers to
comment on your new manifest
portfolio, whatever it is, you
usually have to go find
these people and pay
them for their opinion.
Game developers were paying
Mojang to give
their opinion to them.
This is a completely different
ecosystem that gamers are
willing to justify.
I'm willing to pay you
and tell you how to
make the game better.
That's fantastic, and the
results show themselves.
In 2011, the PC and mobile game
actually shipped, the
stable versions.
And they actually had so many
people that loved the game and
did so many things, they had
the MineCon convention.
How many games do you know
actually start from nothing,
build a community, and actually
have a convention
that ships a couple
of years later?
Today, it's reported that
Minecraft has over 9 million
sales and has lots of
SKUs cross-platform.
This is a perfect example of
shipping early, getting
feedback from users,
and then creating a
success story from it.
Little known fact in the mobile
ecosystem, Angry Birds
was actually the 30th
game that Rovio
shipped in three years.
That's actually a great
statistic, 30
games in three years.
What Rovio was able to do, was
able to ship games quickly,
receive feedback about them
as a unit, as a product--
like, they didn't have the time
to do a full cycle and
say, how do you want this game
to change, and do that for
three years with their
customers.
They would basically make a
product, get information, ship
it quickly, receive as much
feedback as they can from
that, incorporate that into the
next product that allowed
them to be featured once again
in the mobile ecosystem.
Because that's how it works in
mobile right now, is it's
easier to get a new piece of
content featured than it is an
existing piece of content.
So for them to stay on the top
the charts, they had to keep
pushing out new products.
And Angry Birds was the
result of that.
They were able to get feedback
and incorporate it quickly.
A more recent example, a game
called Temple Run, was
actually the 11th game
in four years.
You should be seeing
a trend here.
Game developers who are shipping
more games in the
mobile space are getting better
feedback cycle with
their users.
And then game developers in
the PC space, in the web
space, are able to have better
connectivity with their users
and get more feedback sooner,
allowing them to make a better
product over time.
And the cool thing is, that
once you have the user's
attention, once you're able to
distribute to them from all
the platforms, once you're able
to actually get them in a
dialogue from you, you'll find
it one of the most important
things that you can do
is get them into
your product quickly.
And this is probably the most
technical discussion we're
going to have today about
webify your game.
And it's the concept
of instant on.
If you read the papers about the
internet, you should know
that the internet is ruled by
a law of three seconds.
And that is that a user will
abandon a website if it isn't
loaded in three seconds.
A perfect example of this, a
long time ago, in a galaxy
far, far away, there was a
company called Google who had
a very amazing search engine.
And they actually asked their
users, would you like to see
more results per page?
Would you like 30 results
or 10 results?
Overwhelmingly, of course, the
users of the search engine
said, please give us 30.
When they implemented it and got
all the engineering done,
what they found was that their
click-through traffic actually
dropped about 20%.
And they didn't understand
why.
They implemented what the users
want, but yet they were
losing traffic.
When they went back and looked
at everything, they noticed
that the extra results caused
a half of a second delay in
the site loading.
Half a second of delay was
resulting in 20% of the users
just abandoning the website.
The internet is a consumer's
market.
They understand that
data is everywhere.
And if I think that your site is
slow, and I know that I can
get that data somewhere
else, I'm just going
to exit your site.
Because I feel I can find it
faster than waiting for your
slow site to load.
This is the rule of
the internet.
It's the law.
And there's tons of papers that
have shown personalities
and studies that reflect
that yes, three
seconds is the limit.
Now there's a great quote that
shows that this actually
affects game developers
as well.
There's a great quote from
Rich Helleman, who gave a
fantastic talk at New
Game in 2011.
He says, "Increasingly, the
capacity we are arguing for
with our customers is not their
money, but their time."
Rich understands that the
important thing to do now, in
the ecosystem that we're in now
with gaming, is get the
user's time.
Because the time will
result in the money.
A long time ago with console,
the most important thing to do
was get the money.
Because then the time
came afterwards.
Once I had your purchase, you
would then spend 30 hours
playing my products.
But that was because the
ecosystem wasn't as saturated
as it is today.
Now, game developers are
fighting for nuances of
attention that the user can
spend with their product.
And if they can get your
attention and make you a user,
they know they can get you make
you become a customer.
So now game developers have to
respect the user's time.
This is a great example.
Anyone know this game?
This is Mass Effect 2.
Probably one of the largest
criticisms for this game was
actually their elevator
loading screens.
This actually had a huge
uproar on the internet.
Lots of people were very
critical of this.
In fact, one of the most common
forum posts you could
find is, OMG, WTF, what about
these loading screens?
I could go make a cheeseburger
and come back before the next
level is loaded.
And what you saw here was a very
negative uproar to long
load times.
Now the internet has seen the
same thing in practice.
There's actually been research
that finds that users who
experience slow load times for
a website are more likely to
complain to their friends
about the experience.
Which means that you've not
only lost a current user.
You've actually lost another
potential user who may view
your site as not worth
their time.
In fact, the uproar for Mass
Effect was so large, a very
popular web game comic blog--
blogish--
I don't even know how they even
define themselves anymore.
Anyhow, Penny Arcade did a
comic on this, where they
basically said, this alien
civilization has died from the
ecosystem and I don't
know what happened,
but I have an idea.
It's probably because they all
died in the elevators waiting
to go from floor to floor.
And basically what happened is,
for all the people who had
never played Mass Effect 2,
and this was the only
experience they got was Penny
Arcade saying, whoa, the load
times are too long, there was
a whole pool of customers
who've now been negatively
influenced simply
because of load time.
And it's important to understand
that load time is a
technical problem.
It's not necessarily
a design problem.
Design can hide the technical
limitations.
But in reality, what you're
doing is you're fighting
through multiple stages here.
First off, you've got some
medium, be it compact disc or
actually hard drive, that needs
to get transferred into
memory, and that's typically
limited by the transfer rates
of the medium to memory.
And then from the memory, you've
got to get it back over
the GPU, if you're doing any
sort of rendering, or even
just transform the data into
some form that your system is
going to use.
So loading up a binary trees, or
spatial hierarchies, or A*
path finding.
All that data has got
to be processed.
And so for you to have something
like instant load
times, to get your product
to actually load in three
seconds, you have to optimize
each one of these scenarios
independently.
Another great example is a
game called Half-Life.
This was probably one of the
first that came to the table
with a unique solution.
So for those of you who've
played Half-Life and the
series sort of following--
Half-Life 2, and Left 4 Dead,
and all those other ones--
you'll notice that at the end
of a level, you'll typically
have about 400 foot worth of
additional space for you just
kind of run.
There's no monsters there, you
don't know what's going on.
You're just jumping over
some creates and
running up some ladders.
But then all of the sudden
you'll see this screen, which
is that little loading blip.
And that loading blip will come
on and then disappear.
What the artists and designers
and programmers at Valve were
able to do was actually add
extra geometry into the
environment.
And when you would hit a
specific trigger point, they
would be able to start loading
in the next level of content
while you're running through
these extra 400 foot.
The result was that you would
only see that loading blip for
a very small amount of time.
Rather than having to go through
a full level load,
they were able to predict what
you're going to do and how
you're going to do it, and
start the stream earlier.
Because they knew that the
medium of getting from disk to
memory was the slow part,
and that they could
hide it with design.
So the question we have overall
in instant on is can
your load times be under
three seconds?
Can the gaming community as a
whole adopt this feature of
the internet?
Can your game be instant on?
And what I'm not talking about
here is instant on only from
disk to memory.
So if you're actually doing
digital distribution, and the
user goes in purchases your
content, they're going to have
to wait around for your content
to be downloaded.
I'm not talking about instant
on after this point.
I'm talking about instant on
from the user saying, buy,
thank you, or clicking a link,
or getting a referral, or
having the ability to access
your content for the very
first time, all the way
to actually being
able to play it.
Can they do that in
three seconds?
Now if you're not getting your
product to your user through a
digital distribution platform,
then really, the avenue that
you have to look at is how you
can get content to your users
through the internet.
You'll notice each one of these
arrows has already a ton
of literature out there on how
you can optimize that, how you
can make load times from disk
to memory faster, and memory
to GPU, et cetera, et
cetera, et cetera.
But what really hasn't been
talked about, because it's not
been really conquered yet,
is how you can increase--
or decrease load times from
internet to memory.
So let's talk about
that for a second.
So let's say you have a user who
sits in the United States
and he wants a piece
of content.
Well, that content will be on
some server, sitting in some
basement of some dude's house,
and that content can be
shipped to them over
the inter-tubes.
The issue is, once the user ends
up far, far away, that
the ability to get that content
quickly diminishes.
And this is because
of two factors,
bandwidth and latency.
Now, bandwidth is typically
what you pay for when you
actually go to your internet
service provider.
They usually have some sort of
package system, and they limit
it based upon throttling
all these other things.
But what they're talking about
is buying bandwidth.
The second problem, latency,
you actually can't
control that much.
Latency, or the speed of
latency, is actually limited
by physics, which is actually
limited by how fast light can
travel over time--
or over distance.
Which means that even though
you are buying 100 million
speed connection in America and
they have hundred million
speed connection in Australia,
that data this is going to hit
a limit on how fast you
can get to those
guys across the globe.
How this is fixed is by
duplicating that data.
So rather than allowing that
data to sit only one server,
you allow it to be duplicated
in Australia so that it can
actually get to that
user much quicker.
Now this concept is actually
duplicated in a lot of places.
And you can actually see that by
duplicating the data across
many data centers, you can get
it to users all over the world
very quickly.
Now this is at its
core a content
delivery network, or CDN.
This is sort of the backbone of
the internet, the ability
to distribute content to people
quickly because it's
duplicated in lots of places.
So as a developer, if you want
to get your content, and
you're selling it worldwide, if
you're selling your game,
you need to make sure that
you're using CDNs to
distribute your content.
Now there's some interesting
properties with this.
Let's talk about load
times again.
So let's say the you're a AAA
game, and you have one
gigabyte of content.
That's actually going to take
about seven minutes to
transfer on a 20 megabits
per second connection.
So if you've got one gig, you
want to get it to a user,
that's seven minutes of their
time that they're going to
have to sit around and wait.
So if you assume, just naively,
that that one
gigabyte is uncompressed, then
your first step to say is,
hey, well, what if we just
simply compressed this data?
How fast we get the user?
Gzip is a very standard
compression.
It's supported by most web
servers as well as web
browsers, and the zlib
library, and
lots of other things.
That will actually take a given
set of one gigabyte
content and get down to
about 330 megabytes.
That 330 megs will take about
two minutes and 12 seconds to
transfer and decompress.
Because we have to take into
account the time to actually
decompress the data.
Now, that's fine.
That's great, but can
we get lower?
If you look at the internet,
there's actually some new
cutting edge compression
algorithms out there.
One of them, probably my
favorite, is one called LZHAM.
That will actually take that
same one gig of data and get
it down to about 204 megabytes,
which reduces your
transfer time and decompression
time to one
minute and 18 seconds.
Now this is good, right?
We're starting to see that as
your data gets compressed,
more can come to the
user faster.
Let's take a look at another
thing, using CDNs.
There's an implicit cost
with using a CDN.
So let's say that you've
got some super
successful web game.
And let's say at your best,
you're doing about 3.4 million
unique users a day.
These are people that have
never seen your content
before, coming to your content
for the very first time, and
receiving your content.
Now obviously, this is a worst
case scenario, because if you
get 3.4 million users every day
coming to your game, you
probably don't care about
transfer times.
So that's a separate
discussion.
So if you're actually
transferring 3.4 million users
a day, one gigabyte of data is
actually going to cost you
about $9,600 to get that
data to those users
every single day.
With compression with gzip,
that actually cuts down to
about $2,900.
So you see the number of bits
crossing the wire reduced,
reduce the cost involved with
distributing that content.
And of course, LZHAM then cuts
it down even further, getting
you to about $1,900 a day.
So that's actually still a lot
of data and a lot of cost.
If you have 3.4 million users,
you have to actually take a
look and say, do we need to ship
one gigabyte to a user
before they're allowed to see
a pixel on the screen?
I'm sure if you look at your
assets and you look at your
design, you'll find that that's
not actually the case.
You could probably actually get
a much smaller subset to
your users, allow them to see
the content quickly, and then
stream in the rest
of background.
Which is the concept of, you
should only be sending to
users what they need.
What's the minimal amount of
data you can send to them?
Especially if you're
paying for it.
If you have a user who's not
paying for your content--
let's say you have a freemium
app, or there's a trial
application or something
like that.
These users are connecting to
your servers, downloading your
data, and you're paying for that
transfer for someone who
may not be paying to you.
And so you want to minimize the
amount of data that they
receive that comes out
of your pocket.
There's a great example
of this, a
very successful example.
I hope you all know it.
It's called World of Warcraft.
World of Warcraft came out with
a great streaming demo a
while ago, called Try WoW.
And what Try WoW did, was
effectively bundle the first
25 megabytes of the World of
Warcraft experience into a
single package, a single
executable, that the user
could download very quickly on
a 20 megabits per second pipe
that actually came down around
10 seconds or so.
And then after that, while the
user was configuring their
character and learning a little
bit about the game,
they were actually streaming in
the next 20 hours or so of
gameplay and caching it
locally on the disk.
So the user only actually had
to grab 25 megs first, then
they could start playing
the game.
And then as they started
progressing and experiencing
more content, they would get the
larger and larger pieces
of content coming down.
This allowed the developer of
World of Warcraft to kind of
balance what content came
through the pipe, how much
cost did it take them to acquire
a new user, how much
they were losing to people who
were trying to game but not
actually purchasing of the
content, et cetera.
They had lot more data because
they were segmenting the
content properly.
So now if we assume that
204 megs that LZHAM was
compressing our gig to, and we
tried to bundle it up like
this-- let's say 24 megs went
to two million users a day,
and 172 of that megs one to
1.4 million users a day.
This actually changes your
scale and your cost quite
significantly.
The 24 meg is actually going
to cost you $132 a day.
And then you're going to pay
around $700 for the 172 megs.
The total is about half of
what you were paying by
sending a gig to every user.
And this is a very successful
strategy.
It allows you to also understand
your content and
the deeper level.
It lets you care about what your
users are experiencing,
how they're experiencing, and
what data is needed from your
studio to get them the right
vision of your message.
It's like taking a blog and
compressing into 140 bytes, or
140 characters, so
you can get your
message out to the people.
Now there's a great game that
goes even further than this.
It's a game called Realm
of the Mad God.
Hopefully you've played it.
It's a fantastic product
that's up on the web.
And because it's a web game,
these guys have actually
optimized in a different
direction.
Their entire game
is 1.29 megs.
That's the whole product.
Effectively it's a fantasy
MMO shooter online.
So you've got tons of people
shooting bullets at each other
and dodging.
It's really cool.
The point is that with that 1.29
megs, if they distribute
that to 3.4 million unique
users a day,
that costs them $12.
So they've taken a very unique
approach to the problem.
How small can we make this
product, because load times
matter on the internet.
It takes about 1.3 seconds to
transfer and boot up Realm of
the Mad God the first time
you've played it.
And if 3.4 million users are
getting that content every
day, it only costs
the developer $12
to ship that content.
This is a great intersection
point of understanding
transfer time plus
cost ratios.
And this is where you're going
to have to start optimizing as
game developers.
If you want your content to be
available outside of the
digital distribution platforms
that you have today, so that
you can have a deeper, richer
conversation with your
consumers, you can get feedback
with them earlier,
you need the ability to have
your game load quickly and the
cost of scales involved with
that are minimized.
There's a great quote, and
I'll leave you with this.
"It is not the strongest of the
species that survives, nor
the most intelligent, but the
one most responsive to
change." This is a great
quote about evolution.
What we're seeing in the games
industry right now is a very
evolution-based moment.
We've got tons and tons of
little organisms out there all
fighting for life, trying to
stay stable, trying to create
their own little niches
and ecosystems.
And some will survive,
and some won't.
Your product, your game, your
studio, in order to be
responsive to last out this time
of change, you need to be
willing to adopt new
technologies, new standards of
development, and think in new
ways to reach your customer.
And that is the basis of
webifying your game.
Thank you so much
for your time.
I appreciate it.
We'll go to questions here
in a minute, once they
kill the live feed.
Again, I'm Colt McAnlis.
This is how you get
a hold of me.
Go, webify your game.
Make things awesome.
Thank you very much.